dr. who queefs
[Music]
my pubic hair is too curly I don't know
if it's the humidity so a bird pooped on
me today is my nipple too hairy is it
okay if my nipples go like this
my crotch itches is it because of my
underwear I'm really worried about the
white lump in my baby's gum I went to
the gym yesterday and my arms are
hurting is that weird
Oh a tooth just kidding I think I might
be allergic to avocado hey I only ate
like a doctor my testicle swing way too
much doctor how does one queef
it's like Newton's Cradle down there
it's not okay can you clean my skin is
too soft do you want to touch it so I'm
getting a pap smear today and I was just
wondering if there's gonna be a woman
coming in because I don't want a man
sticking his hand a black thing you know
is it normal to grow pubic hair on other
parts of your body because I think I see
some what can I do to feel fresh
downstairs
I can't fart without making noise do i
Febreze it say II just like a little
squirt doctor why is one boob like
bigger than the other what if I you know
rub some deodorant you know my treasures
my womanly good or as they say flower